hello today we're gonna talk about the
baseball pitcher Jim Abbott cheers my
chums
so Jim Abbott who's born in 1967 but he
didn't have a right hand and so when he
was like five or six Jim was like I
wanna play sports
Jim's that Mike is like you should maybe
think about soccer soccer is the
Europeans far with feet you don't have
to use your hands actually the only rule
in soccer still use your hands and Jim's
like nah I'm not a European I'm an
American I want to play baseball
his parents loved him they were like
even though you can't do any of
everything dream anything there he you
had to develop his own method to play
baseball he used to practice against the
wall in his backyard then he would go
closer and closer and closer as he got
older until he was right up against the
wall I'm catching it like that and his
first Little League game effort he
pitched a no-hitter you put you nine
inning game and no one gets a hit so
then after you have the no-hitter years
later word got out to the high school
coaches and they were like he can throw
a ball sure but what if someone hits a
ball to him and as soon as he said that
Jim was like you will see this pitch
[Applause]
hard grounder straited Jim Abbott
and glove throw out at first base all
within like a half a second so fast and
a high school coach was like oh never
mind you just answer my question
put him on my team I'm gonna ask oh
Jesus Christ wine is the devil okay
we're yet oh I got it I got it I got it
throughout his high school career he put
four no-hitters including a perfect game
so he gets his education place for the
University of Michigan the Wolverines
when he got there
you're so much press there after the two
bad games people are like he sucks this
is a publicity stunt this guy is not a
real pitcher or just trying to be nice
to a kid with a handicap and all of the
press left when when when hey come on
come on ear and lay down
once they left started pitching enemies
lay down lay down fat banana she was not
only good pitcher but he's a good batter
what hit homeruns they went over and
over his leg I throw these 90 miles an
hour in the 80s they the year in 1980s
not in the eighties of speedball oh
Jesus I gotta try that ya know you're
fun so I'm gonna throw the ball in the
80s miles per hour in the 1990s which is
very impressive and you switch them up
so I'm Jim Abbott right I'm throwing the
ball in the 90s in the 1980s it's very
impressive
gosh I'm Abbott and Costello yeah Jim
Abbott she was playing baseball like he
said he would they were like putting
together the national team and they're
like I don't know if he can do it but
it's good PR let's do it they put him on
the national team
[Music]
he gets put in the national team and the
national team
take him down at the pan-american games
and the biggest superpower in the
pan-american games his Cuba Fidel
Castro's Cuba because Fidel loves
communism and he loves baseball those
are a couple of things he loves
there is a huge separation between the
American and Cuban regime
Jim Abbott walks out and starts for
America and everybody in the place is
like oh we're Cuban the greatest
baseball players in the world how can
you possibly think you can beat us
Americans with two hands can be this
[Music]
he was like oh it's nice that you're
Cuban I wish
his performance in the pan-american
kubja games was so remarkable and by in
the game 50,000 cubans they gave him a
standing ovation when he left the field
there were no Americans in the stand
because they were not allowed in Cuba
and like Fidel Castro came down shook
his hand and was like nice was a big
deal tell an American glare nice anyone
on to play for like ten years in the
major leagues every step of the way high
school college majors people said can
you do it he was such a positive person
he would say stuff like everyone asks
disabilities mine are just more visible
it makes everybody feel that they're in
his camp it's incredible her respect
edge look at your limitations and say
few limitations I'm gonna do whatever I
want and that's the American dream
what else you want talk about
you